hey there I'm David DeAngelo developer
Yacht Club games I'm here to run you
through all of our inspirations for
shovel knight and how we came about
designing them for shovel knight we were
really interested in making an nes style
game that in modernizing in a way that
would be interesting to everyone the
mechanics that we were really inspired
by it we're sort of these old abandoned
or forgotten ideas I think as a company
we like to try to take these ideas and
sort of show people hey this is why this
is cool and it shouldn't forget been
forgotten or this is something that
everyone said was bad but this is why
it's good or if you mix and match these
in some kind of fun new interesting way
this is why I could be engaging so one
of the main inspirations for sunlights
gameplay was zelda 2 surprisingly a lot
of people think it comes from ducktales
but in fact it didn't the main main
mechanics we were working with here
where we wanted to do a Down thrust we
saw there's Elda two down thrust and it
was we thought you get that game you get
that mechanic late in the game and it's
sort of hard to see all the possible
ways you can use it we felt like it you
could explore a whole game with just
that and then we also liked the idea of
making that like a one-two punch
so essentially you would flip an enemy
over and put and then try to like attack
their underbelly we decided there needed
to be some kind of scooping mechanic and
some kind of attacking from above
mechanic and that's why we landed with a
shovel so yeah we did this down thrust
mechanic as you can see which we call
the shovel drop when shovel Knight hits
an enemy he'll bounce up so we were
trying to take the platforming
components maybe from like a Mario game
when you jump on an enemy right you
might say Oh down down thrusting that's
from DuckTales I say no it's from Mario
and in our game when you bounce off a
guy you typically get a big bounce and
on some guys when we're trying to make
it more of a combat focused encounter
we're calling back to that Zelda tube
we're giving you a small bounce here we
got a encounter with a gold armor this
is sort of our staple enemy for if we
knew our combat would be working you can
see I have the short bounce I'm talking
about
is like that big right in the other area
the bounces would be more for
platforming mobility so they'd be much
larger so this here is to try to keep
you engaged in the combat right we don't
want to make you do a huge bounce
because if we do a huge bounce it's not
going to be fun you're gonna it's going
to be so much time in between the
interactions we're just trying to reduce
that a little bit more and make it about
the down thrust and just a straight up
attack so there's two main things we're
thinking about that we pulled from Zelda
that we thought were exciting ideas one
this character is flashing when he gets
hit this indicates to the player that
they've been damaged was just exciting a
nice fun way to do that so when they
flash you won't be hurt by them anymore
and that's important because it gives a
lot of leniency in the way you can
attack and like prepare yourself for any
follow-ups or anything like that I would
say it's something that makes the game
feel more generous than a lot of NES
games might have felt with her punishing
difficulty so you can see in that
encounter right right here shovel knight
gets pushed back that distance after he
does a hit and this is another way of
creating an exciting engaging encounter
hopefully so instead of being in their
face and being able to just wail on them
like you might do in say a Devil May Cry
game which is fun for another reason we
were trying to create a more deliberate
feeling combat where you know you try to
go in and get the hit and then it's a
slight reset of like what do I do next
one big component of what we are
thinking about when making shovel
knight' was how to make a compelling
structure to the game and by that I mean
the metagame what you encounter once
you're outside of the stage and one of
the things that kept coming up to us is
most exciting from the NES era that has
hadn't really been used that effectively
it was this world map and I think Mario
3 is one of the games that did the best
job of sort of showing what that could
be like in a contained space where it's
not just an open field that you can
wander for miles and miles this very
beginning is extremely linear right but
when you get to somewhere like here you
get a choice of where to go and there's
a clear reward or some kind of like what
is that over there maybe I should take
this what seems like an optional path
right we were trying to do the same
thing in shovel knight' trying to
display a map trying to make options for
the player different places they could
go to or decisions they can make and
still keep it mostly linear focused
stage design in there we wanted to have
a somewhat linear path you start in this
open this teaches you everything most of
the mechanics you need to know in the
main game but from there we have a lot
of choices here are the two main stages
you need to go to in the map when it's
first starts out there's a little lock
here so you know oh I need to beat these
two stages in order to progress and you
obviously generally know you start on
the left you're trying to go to the
right because there's nowhere to go on
the left so when you get to here we're
trying to make this be this flexible
somewhat in between Mario someone in
between Megaman where it still got this
all these are core stages I need a play
but I have these options of oh I went
into Pridemore and it's too too easy or
this is too hard
or I like dip into one and then I go
back to the village and I upgrade we
tried to get as many as much flexibility
in this map as possible while still
still making it this fun and engaging
thing you could do
one of the fun old NES ideas we liked
that was just really common in the 80s
is creating a character IP modern games
have the benefit of having a so much
text as they want to having much
dialogue and cutscenes and all that and
the NES didn't really get to benefit
from that kind of thing so but we wanted
to keep it still focused on the gameplay
so you can see here as when I walk in
I'm gonna fight bomb man and bomb man
just appears on the screen
oh isn't that so sad it doesn't say much
about his character we're thinking about
how do we amplify that like initial
moment of you meeting the character to
give it just just so you feel like I
know exactly who this is so here we have
the play night boss fight and you'll
notice something very obvious right away
there's dialogue we didn't want to add
too much script to this game we wanted
to keep it so we're still really focused
on the gameplay but we wanted to add
these light story moments so the the
second part of the boss battles that we
really liked in Megaman and the
character designs was that they're
really simple they take you one or two
tries they have this really natural
feeling gameplay to them so the way that
we found that they did their boss fights
and made them really engaging and also
not too complicated for the player to do
or not having to go through these all
these crazy faces was they focused on a
really small set of moves and they made
it really player focused he will throw a
bomb a certain distance towards Megaman
so you can see he's got two types of
bombs each there was a short bomb and a
long bomb and he's always trying to hit
the player so no matter where he's
standing on the screen it's covered and
as a player I know exactly the kind of
moves he can do he can only do this
simple bomb toss at me and I immediately
understand what I need to do to avoid it
so we wanted to try to create similar
kind of tensions okay so you can see
just like bomb man he does these big
jumping arcs and they're aimed at the
player the difference here being in our
game that he does one two and three jump
where the third is a bigger jump so that
gets combined with the very similar
idea from Batman that he throws a bomb
at the player so it's really simple
player created randomness essentially
the other fun component this the thing
in this battle though we are trying to
think how do we make this special how do
we make this unique what do we make it
that's something you haven't seen before
and this boss fight it was all about the
blocks here so we thought how do we take
this player create a randomness and
multiply it by a million and the way we
did that is when he throws this these
bombs they're gonna come and land on the
ground and destroy these blocks so now
is it not only a battle about me
recognizing his attacks being able to
handle them
but it becomes a platforming challenge
of how do i integrate with what I've
learned with this ever changing terrain
once you're used to these patterns he's
going to introduce new things and these
are more variations on the same theme if
the players in the right spot he'll
throw a bomb that hits that Metra makes
a much bigger boom a much different
reaction from these blocks so the it's
different different ways of toying with
that same idea in engaging ways while
keeping the mechanics really simple
right in the end he still has not that
many moves compared to a Mega Man boss
he's only jumping and throwing bombs and
he's spawning those blocks and that's
all we have to worry about ok so a fun
bit in shovelknight that everyone loves
or hates are these money bags
when shovelknight here unfortunately
falls into this pit or runs out of life
he'll drop a percentage of his gold when
we were playing these old nes games one
of the things we found was there wasn't
a lot of encouragement to keep going
when we played mmo's or games like Dark
Souls that use these corpse runs
mechanics where you're essentially going
back trying to recover your stuff they
provided a really huge incentive and
story - what - replaying the game
content when shovel Knight falls in a
pit we tried things like oh he's gonna
drop the bags here or whatever or but we
ended up with these flying these flying
money bags and we thought not only that
they provide you motivation or this
story like hey I got my money bags back
and I feel really happy or I didn't get
my money bags
and I feel like crap they added new
platforming challenges right now as
shovel knight is going through he has to
contend with the fact that there's these
moving objects that he really desires so
it creates this fun second loop of
playing the game because at first all he
had to worry about was jumping on this
platform right and now the second time
that it's being played it's this new
consideration of I have to do it like
this because I really want to get my
gold back and when I get to this pit
over here
I have to really think how do I even get
that this has now become a puzzle one of
the iconic elements I think of shovel
knight is him laying at the campfire and
you might wonder where that came from
well it was also inspired by old ideas
one of the things we were trying to
think about was one how do we convey
story without putting a book in front of
your face how do we do it in an
interesting and engaging way that
involves gameplay and two how do we
create these moments of respite so we
were looking at these games like golden
axe where he sits at a campfire and it's
a fun relaxing thing to it golden axe is
this fun thing where it made this
respite moment feel a little bit like it
has some gameplay to it it's almost like
a minigame in between stages so this
guy's going to come up here and try
screw up your stuff and it's not quite
like the main gameplay it's not as
worrisome and all that but it gives you
something different that you can either
look forward to or makes the the
onslaught of stage after stage after
stage not feel so daunting so here's the
shovel knight equivalent it's telling a
little story he's he's resting in
between these big scenes right we got
our classic campfire here we've got a
little bit of a reward like Oh something
to look forward to great what we tried
to do with these campfires was make them
not all be stressful make some of them
be stressful so you might have noticed
if you've played the game only every
third one has a sequence that goes into
this minigame section like when you go
to sleep and you have dreams sometimes
it's not always consistent right
so shield night will only fall some of
the times that you're sitting down at
that campfire and we wanted to give that
same kind of story where he's struggling
with this event that happened in his
life and he's having nightmares about it
so at some points in the game you just
have to catch her right but at other
points in the game you have to contend
with almost like a nightmare these
enemies that you've seen throughout the
stages you just played
so this first campfire has these enemies
I witnessed in the previous stages that
I had to fight to get here it provides a
sort of like satisfaction that I've
mastered these kind of enemies right
I've already seen a bunch of these these
enemies actually spawn a bunch more gold
than normal so it feels more like a
bonus time fun thing
hopefully rather than if I die I'm
screwed and like in a main stage with
with shovel knight we tried to bring
back these old ideas and we try to show
that everything here has worth
everything we can we can find a way to
make things work and combine together in
special ways and we hope that when you
play shovel Knight you you go back to
those games and you give them a shot and
you can see the value in them you can go
back to a game like Zelda 2 and you can
say well there's there's fun ways to
play this game there's a ways to enjoy
it maybe if I just have a guide by my
side that will solve the problem of
wandering into that first cave and I'm
totally in the dark there's like real
inherent value I think and a lot of the
ideas that all these developers have put
forth through all these years you know
we're going forward as a company as
Jakob I think we we are going to try to
keep pushing those you know making
people understand that those are like
valuable things and we hope we hope at
the end of the day you like dig through
your your dad's NES collection and you
find that cool game that like you know
is fun for you
[Music]
you